out of here how does it go that man my
name is beautiful that gentleman was
saying that we need to get out of here
but I'm like why it was his naked guy I
wanted to make out with me he came out
of the closet which is ironic but yeah I
guess we're finally ready to live this
hellish [ __ ] house which makes me a
little happy I felt happy and snappy and
added a lot of other things
iPod iPad have you seen my cousins I'm
worried about them I think someone
killed him I heard them screaming
that's why you're going to run down I
went oh yeah that's right you are with
your cousins now [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] my
heartbeat sensor doesn't want to work
today I don't know why now I think I can
leave now
yes climbing down there why do I always
beat bugs like that well the moon is
here the chairs are in perfect place I
do believe we can go here now because we
still have our crowbar thing in like jig
advanced rapper all right do you think
it's gonna work for us you don't you
think
well let's David yes I was right Iowa
said I did me
all right you [ __ ] why don't you
wanna hang on
I recognize this room okay that's where
I grew up this is my house yeah this is
where I used to shovel the walls I love
dinner Wow memories this is where I put
that in a box good please stuck my
friend Owain thinks that what an ugly
house you had there oh all righty then
we're all back in our house hopefully
everything's working
hello chef
blah Hilal oh she looks a bit like Sarah
Silverman's lesbian wife I don't know
why they will look some love you why
thank God yes they are I've seen them
like that tiny dog yeah shut up and go
to sleep
back in my day we just bitch-slap I had
children to make them sleep way bad in
my day way bad in my days alrighty then
it would appear that pills doesn't
really know where to go
perhaps it Borden up and cannot be open
it's locked with a simple lock huh and a
simple lock must have a key and a star
oh it's one of those ninja stars I love
them I do like this look at this 36 day
I hit her right in the face
you saw it 10 points for peds 10 points
for you for noticing yet a big up Simon
that I told you not to go near that
painting it's valuable ah
and it's okay there's our job alright
it's a safe the master key has been
created as you requested it can open the
lock to every house in the village I
left it on your desk in the morgue
please come see me as soon as you get
this morgue why did you have to put it
in the morgue
any place would have been better hello
shot had a buck that's right Burke you
rest
you got a sleep bag take your stupid
wife with you another note dear Clarissa
and William I'm sorry to hear about
Elizabeth this comes quite as a shock to
me her disappearance means nothing
though she could still turn up any day
now don't lose hope I'll be praying for
her safe return in the meantime I would
gladly take care of Simon until there
things get better no matter how long
then that
maybe because that village doesn't seem
safe anymore it'll be good for Simon to
come to London and lay there for a while
as it needs to take his mind off his
sister please consider my offer if you
need anything else I'm here for you
I love you I'll be you'll be in my
prayers
sincerely Simon and Elizabeth on and
Alan punch your [ __ ] bags oh you're
coming with me painting I think you
could get away that easily huh he
thought that well you're a smart
painting aren't you protect us Margaret
I toss em everywhere potatoes well it
looks like we need to go to the morgue
this is that I really don't [ __ ] want
to go through the more I need to go to
the Graveyard all right before it said
like I don't need to go to the Graveyard
yet because I'm a [ __ ] but it looks
like I we have to go anyway climbing up
the ladder hit my head ouch oh how do
you bros feel about graveyards you like
them why that is probably a touchy
subject matter I think about it never
mind that I was a bit awkward that's a
bit awkward sorry about that but a
libros feel about your vagina fountains
how about that with baby screaming over
them [ __ ] love that baby face by the
way
I think that it's like a statue of me
I'm vitiate celebrating kids all right
that's where we [ __ ] came from where's
the graveyard it's over here it's
[ __ ] creepy man
go barrel
[Music]
they chanted with me [ __ ]
I think we're [ __ ] breaths I don't
know about you but I think we're [ __ ]
hello cemetary ahead yeah what's up this
is gonna go really well
oh what a coincidence did I see you guys
here
I'm watching you [ __ ] okay then
what a nice little cave you go through
that's lovely I guess I'll I'll just
keep walking nothing dude I don't like
this
I really don't [ __ ] like this [ __ ] is
that
oh yeah there were custom monsters
[Music]
hello Margaret
it's a yeah that's a tea time already
alrighty then okay I thought I had an
office this is not looking like an
office if you ask pills and pills does
not need to ask many questions we're
[ __ ]
we're [ __ ] we're [ __ ] we're so
[ __ ] there's lying stop lie on me out
okay we're here let's go inside the
correct or whatever the [ __ ] not [ __ ]
what about you guys do do strikes again
nail that [ __ ] I nailed that [ __ ] I
name net net net nailed a bit I'm sorry
about that oh [ __ ] well there's only one
way Adam here that way and I'm going
away from it quite nicely sighing good
condition
ah shut I did and just cave then I did
find out the way out
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't worry I have this
toenail clipper Thank You combination
for the safe in my bedroom first digit
is 4 less than the number of houses in
the village uh-huh
second dude is the first letter of my
daughter's name uh-huh third L is the
right of my house it's to the right of
my house final date is the amount of
rooms available in the end that seems
like quite too troublesome [ __ ]
safe my [ __ ] [ __ ] but at least we can
go in all the houses now the only
problem is we're [ __ ] locked in here
and and I only have this toenail clipper
Oh JA blood Oh job daddy okay we're
hiding quite a bit it how do you even
talk you're a [ __ ] toe is it a snake
No No
Oh [ __ ]
we go with the party and the barrel
house shut up
shut the [ __ ] up oh my god it doesn't
sound very friendly no it does not
we're fine we're fine friends friends
are fine that's how I roll that's what
friends are for
hello jumpluff ani phonic jam la fête
coke hope you're all [ __ ] happy aren't
you
why the hell am i good condition my deck
[ __ ] you
fly [ __ ] oh that's right what are you
doing Tetris block god [ __ ] [ __ ]
this wall doesn't look sturdy I can
probably find a Toland emerge the
breaker tollable about well what about
the toenail clipper why of course
[ __ ] well I'm putting you there so I
know I've been here before right sure
didn't I tell you to [ __ ] fly
[Music]
nice fun it's fine
it's [ __ ] fine
okay I think we lost him sick of this
[ __ ] Timms does not play games pills is
not [ __ ] around all right you hear that
I didn't want to throw the [ __ ] bells
cuz I'm I'm scared I'll alert that [ __ ]
my glass jar come here my [ __ ] what
else
whatta [ __ ] [ __ ] well I think
that's Albany but ah well [ __ ]
splendid ok ok I think we need some
[Music]
it's not even [ __ ] funny
this is like the [ __ ] pressing in the
Mesha all over the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's so
evil I don't know it's one that's what I
tell you yes this glass jar container
what about the master cake
you think the master cave would ever be
on for the elephant what do you think
about the case you're as well
ha ha know what see if I care
see how much I can pop let's lick behind
the desk done its [ __ ] we're fine
what bit that [ __ ] [ __ ] hmm well
[ __ ] nothing aren't you we all have
to here ok
flatten pits let's go the [ __ ] back and
[ __ ] yourselves
how about that how about that how about
that how about that how about by [ __ ]
that there you go stupid [ __ ] wig
what have a bed in here I don't even
know it him oh it was here a little [ __ ]
you just chilling here suck my dick
suck it hey hey suck it suck it suck it
suck
[Laughter]
[Music]
baby darlin
[Music]